[Musique]
et on commence avec cette information
Gabriel un trè satellite ivinois sera
bientôt mis en orbite oui c'est une
nouvelle presse scientifique pour les
chercheurs de l'Université de Versailles
51 en Eveline un nouveau satellite va
être envoyé dans l'espace lancement
prévu pour 2025 et il s'agit du 3è mini
satellite conçu et piloté par le Latmos
le laboratoire atmosphère observation
spatiale le objectif de ce satellite
nommé UVSQ sat NG étudier le dérèglement
climatique en particulier le bilan
radiatif de la Terre les données seront
ensuite collectées à Guill en cours par
le Latmos l'opération est menée à la
fois par l'UVSQ Sorbon université et le
CNRS et un rendez-vous plus terre à
terre maintenant mais pas moins attendu
la 3e édition du Prix du livre les
visionnaires fait son grand retour oui
Régine cette année encore le réseau des
médithèques de SaintQuentin en yeline
propose une sélection de de fiction
portant un regard singulier sur notre
monde et traitant des des interrogations
d'aujourd'hui trois romans sont en
compétition pour cette nouvelle édition
les terres animales de Laurent Petit
Mangin panorama de Lilia Hassen et enfin
Rocky dernier rivage de Thomas ginzin
vous avez jusqu'au 26 avril 2024 pour
voter pour votre roman préféré
rendez-vous donc sur le site internet de
Saint-Quentin en ibline et on va parler
de sport notamment avec l'arrivée de
Louis Burton et de Davy Bauda en
Martinique oui depuis ce dimanche 19
novembre les arrivées se succèdent pour
les imoka sur la transate Jacques Vabre
après 2 semaines en mer le skipper
rambolitin Louis Burton accompagné de
Davy Baudard est arrivé cet après-midi à
16h58 et 23 secondes à bord de bureau
Vallée il se positionne donc 16e au
classement général prochain rendez-vous
pour le skipper le vent des globes
l'année prochaine et on poursuit avec du
basket l'équipe des Spurs du native du
chénero cancour Victor wembanama
encaissé sa 9e défaite consécutive oui
hier soir les Spurs de sint anonio
affronté les Los Angeles Clippers à
l'issue du match les Texans sont
repartis avec une 9e défaite de suite
dans leur valise l'équipe conserve donc
sa dernière place au classement de la
Conférence Ouest de son côté Victor
wembanama s'est montré discret avec
seulement 9 points trois rebonds quatre
passes et deux contres nouvelle soirée
difficile donc pour l'équipe prochain
match pour les Spurs dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi où ils recevront à
nouveau les de Los Angeles et bien merci
beaucoup Gabriel et si vous aussi vous
êtes témoin d'une actualité qui vous
fait réagir n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le #t 78 news